we are almost ready to develop a fast
algorithm for finding the to break
distance the only thing left for us to
accomplish it is to prove the to break
distance theory let's consider an
arbitrary transformation of genome P
into genome Q we don't know what two
breaks accomplish this transformation
but what we know is that during this
transformation the breakpoint graph of p
and q changes into the breakpoint graph
of q which is itself which means that
the cycle number of p and q is changing
into the cycle number of q with itself
which in turn is simply the number of
blocks in Q 0 for whatever
transformation of P and Q accomplishes
it the number of red-blue cycles
increases by number of blocks in the
genomes p or q - number of cycles
between P and Q and therefore the next
question I will ask how much each to
break can contribute to this increase in
the number of cycles let's look in this
well there are different scenario
depending on which to read edges from
the breakpoint graph to break effects
every to break removes two red edges
consider first the case when these two
red edges belong to the same cycle in
the breakpoint graph in this case shown
on this slide two red edges are removed
substituted by another two red edges but
the cycle number doesn't change here's
another case where the same two red
edges are removed from a single cycle in
the breakpoint graph but the cycle
number this time increases by one and
now let's consider the case when to
remove red edges belong to two different
cycles you can see that in this case
doesn't matter which
two red edges replace these remove red
edges the cycle number doesn't change
actually the cycle number decreases by
one in this case and therefore each to
break increases the number of cycles but
if most one we almost prove this area
but actually we haven't proved it yet my
previous slide was simply an invitation
for you to look in the picture let's
give a little bit more formal proof so a
to break adds two new red edges and thus
creates it moves to new cycles in the
breakpoint graph on the other hand it
removes two red edges and thus destroy
at least one old cycle in the breakpoint
graph and therefore the change in the
number of cycle is at most two minus one
which is at most one and on the other
hand if you watch carefully my proof
then you notice there is always a to
break increasing number of cycles by one
and here it is the central case here
present an example of such increase and
now the to break distant cerium this so
that each to break increases the number
of cycles by it.most one on the other
hand zero existed to break increasing
the number of cycles by exactly one on
the other hand to be so that every
sorting by to break must increase the
number of cycles by number of blocks
between P and Q minus number of cycles
between P and Q and therefore the to
break distance between genomes P and Q
is simply number of blocks between P and
Q minus number of cycles between P and Q
and our new visitor serum they actually
can compute the to break distance
between circularized
human and mouse Rama so we know that
human and mouse genomes can be
decomposed into 280 synteny blocks each
of this block will be larger than half a
million nucleotides in length the
breakpoint graph on this block if we
look at this actually contains 35 cycles
and therefore the to break distance
between human and mouse equal to 245
remember this number because it will be
important in the next section now the
run numerous 245 steps in area and we do
not claim that we know which one of them
is correct
moreover the true scenario may have more
than 245 step important thing for us is
to remember that there were at least two
forty five steps to proceed to our next
section where we will analyze the random
breakage model